في مونديال قطر 2022 سيكتشف الجمهور
تقنيات تكنولوجيا استثنائيه تدخل لاول مره
عالم كره القدم وبطولات كاس العالم من
اهمها التسلل شبه الالي المعروف باس اي او
تي هذا النظام قادر على ارسال تنبيه عند
حدوث تسلل في الوقت الحقيقي لطاق من
التحكيم وهو تطوير لتقنيه الفار يسمح
بتفادي اضاعه الوقت
يعتمدوا على ما لا يقل عن اثني عشره
كاميرا تتابع كل لاعب وتراقب جسمه بمعدل
50 مره في الثانيه
وبدمج البيانات وتطبيق الخوارزميات يرسل
النظام تنبيها تلقائيا بحدوث تسلل
التقنيه الثانيه هي الكره التي اطلق عليها
اسم الرحله تعملوا هذه الكره بنظام
استشعار حركه وفره اديداس يرسل البيانات
500 مره في الثانيه ما يمكن من نقلها في
الوقت الفعلي لحكام الفيديو تقنيه تبريد
الملاعب سبعه من ملاعب المونديال الثمانيه
تستخدم تقنيه التبريد المتقدم وهي تقنيه
ثوريه تعمل بطاقه الشمسيه وتدفع الهواء
البارده الى الملعب واماكن جلوس المشجعين
ملعبوا 974 هو اول ملعب قابل للتفكير بني
باستخدام حاويات عددها
974 وهو رمز الاتصال الدولي لقطر وهو ملعب
قابل للتفكيك والتركيب بالكامل
تقنيه بنقل تمكن المكفوفين وضعاف البصر من
متابعه البطوله بتحويل المحتوى الى طريقه
برايل ويستخدم فيها جهاز الكترونيا مبتكر
يعتمد على تقنيه البلوتوث وفي اطار
الاهتمام بدوي الاعاقه تم ايضا انشاء غرف
مشاهده حسيه في الملاعب لتوفير المساحات
امنه وهادئه للمصابين بالتوحد صممت لاشراك
حواسهم في العروض التفاعليه مع اضاءه
متحكم من فيها تطبيق نفدي قطر للتنقل وطلب
الطعام يسهل على المشجعين الوصول الى
اماكن شراء الطعام ودورات المياه القريبه
منهم وتفادي الاماكن المستحمه
تقنيه شحن الهواتف بسرعه ابطال في محطات
خاصه من خلال منافذ يو اس بي او لاسلكيا
وتمكن ايضا من الاتصال بشبكه الواي فاي
تعتمد ملاعب مونديال قطر على اضاءه ليد
غير الضاره والتي توفر الطاقه وتعمر طويلا
تتويق
في اسرع وقت ممكن يحمل على الهواتف لتقديم
خدمه التوصيل الى المقاعد ومحطات النقل
والاماكن الرياضيه خلال مونديال قطر
ستستخدم حافلات كهربائيه صديقه للبيئه
لنقل المشجعين من وائل الملاعب واماكن
اخرى وهي مجازه بتكنولوجيا المعلومات
عاليه الدقه لضمان قياده صديقه للبيئه
وهذه اول مره تستخدم فيها حافلات كهربائيه
في كاس العالم